And the answer here is that, well, this approach, number one,
it in principle works for any problem in NP,
so that is not the issue with this approach,
and this approach is, of course, is also always correct
because if you can show that you can reduce
an NP-complete problem to another problem,
that problem here becomes NP-complete as well.
The issue is that it's a bit of a chick in an egg problem,
because in order to be able to use this approach,
you must first have an NP-complete problem,
and unless you have one NP-complete problem,
this approach here will fail,
so you need a kind of seed problem
that you show to be NP-complete using this approach here
before you can use the more convenient approach down here.
So unfortunately, while we would always like to work with approach number one,
we can only do so if we have had success with approach number two
at least once.